حدود أستراليا مغلقة أمام معظم
المسافرين بسبب تغطية 19 ،
لكنني مواطن أسترالي واضطررت
إلى العودة إلى المنزل لحضور
جنازة وأنا أعيش وأعمل
كمصور صحفي لـ
CNN الآن في هونغ كونغ. غادرت هونغ كونغ
في وقت متأخر  يوليو وعادة ما يكون المطار
مزدحمًا ،
لقد اندهشت تمامًا لرؤية كيف
كان المطار فارغًا ، حيث أصبحت
هناك المزيد من البلدان المخيفة في
جميع أنحاء العالم تطلب من
المسافرين الحجر الصحي عند الوصول ،
وقد تشعر بالفضول لمعرفة ما
قد يبدو عليه
ذلك جيدًا  يعتمد على مدى صرامة القواعد
الخاصة بالمكان الذي تتجه إليه ،
تتطلب بعض البلدان مثل كوريا الجنوبية
تنزيل تطبيق تعقب على
هاتفك للتأكد من بقائك في
مكان واحد لمدة 14
يومًا في الولايات المتحدة والدول الأخرى من ناحية أخرى
الاعتماد على الأشخاص لمجرد التصرف
بمسؤولية
وقد يقوم شخص ما بتسجيل الوصول إليك عبر الهاتف
أو حتى يتأرجح بجوار موقع الحجر الصحي الخاص
بك لمعرفة ما إذا كنت تفعل ما قلته
، فلن يكون الأمر كذلك في أستراليا
[Musi  ج]
عندما نزلت من الطائرة في مطار سيدني ،
كان هناك مرافقون عسكريون وطاقم
طبي لاستقبالي ،
لقد حصلت على حافلة فارغة نقلتني إلى
فندق فخم في المنطقة التجارية المركزية ،
يبدو الأمر جيدًا ، لكن انتظر فقط
كان علي أن أمضي أسبوعين في  هذه
الغرفة التي تبلغ مساحتها 32 مترًا مربعًا
مع استثناءات قليلة ، يتعين على المسافرين
إلى أستراليا الحجر الصحي في
منشأة مخصصة من قبل الحكومة
، ومعظمهم يدفعون ثمنها بأنفسهم ، أي
شخص يحجز رحلة إلى أستراليا بعد
12 يوليو ، عليه أن يدفع
ما يزيد قليلاً عن 2000 دولار أمريكي
ليعلق في أستراليا.  غرفة لمدة أسبوعين
لتمضية الوقت الذي أعددت فيه روتينًا يتضمن
التمرين على اللحاق بقراءة العائلة لمشاهدة
التلفزيون
وفي أحد الأيام شعرت بالملل لدرجة أنني
قررت أن أكون مبدعًا مع
الأطباق الورقية وأدوات المائدة
التي كانت عالقة في الغرفة  سريالية
خاصة وأن هذا البلد
كان دائمًا بيتي ، فقد
أخذت حرياتي كمواطن
أمرا مفروغا منه حتى تلك اللحظة في
النهاية تمكنت من ذلك خلال
الأسبوعين وتمكنت من المغادرة
وجعلتها  لجنازة الأسرة